.
Let's put some line equations into the point-tilt model
This is different from the Y model or the intersection of inclination
Model of intersection of inclination
But they are actually two different ways to write
Equation itself
We will see this through a set of examples
Perhaps you remember that the model of the intersection of inclination is about
Equations on model image, y = mx + b - We have done
This is in the last view - when m was the tilt, and b is
Intersection y
For this reason the intersection is called tilt
Where we have the inclination and intersection
Model tilt point, takes the shape y-y1 --- and
I'll tell you what y1 is fast - = m × x
- x1, where point x1, y1 falls on line
This is why it is called the tilt point model
Now, there are two different ways to write
the same thing
You can always manipulate it compulsively to get it
Or to manipulate it so you get it
I will show you this through a set of examples
But let's put a set in a point-tilt model, so we make
Things are clear in your mind
If we have here a 1 /
10, if m = -1.10
And passes point 10.2
We can go directly to the model point of inclination
Let's take a point
The point here is 10.2
We can go directly to the model point of inclination. y -
This is the y value that is on the line
If y-2 is equal to inclination, -1
/ 10 x x - x value, x x - 10
So
We're done
We put it in a model
There are two things I want to point out to them
The first thing, why this makes sense
I also want to show you that
Equal to that
So what is the first thing that makes sense?
Well, all that is said here, if you split both ends
Equation on it, you will get y2 / x -
10 = 1 / 10-
Or you will get a change in y between any point and 2, and
Point 2, / change in x
If you get the change in y / change in x for any
Point for x, y on that line, relative to point 10,
2, will become 1 / 10-
This is the definition of inclination
I hope I did not fight you here
I'll show you that just use this to define
The tendency is to be equal to the line
Now, the last thing I want to explain to you is that this
Equally equal to that
We can manipulate it so we get it
Let us do that
This is the answer to the question
But let's manipulate it even geographically
We get out this picture
If we get y - 2 = - let us distribute
1 / 10-
It's 1 / 10x-, then 1 / 10-
× 10 = positive 1
Now we can add 2 to both ends of the equation
We get y = -1 / 10x + 3
By manipulating them geographically, we will be able
To put them in the tilt point model
If these are exactly equal
Let's solve more questions. The line contains
The points are 10,12 and 5.25
Let's find the inclination
The slope, which is equal to the change in y / change in
x, = - Well, let's use this point first
Let it be 12 - 25/10 - 5
This equals -12 - 25 = -13
/ 10 - 5 = 5
If the tendency here is 13 / 5-
Let's put it in the model of the point of inclination, the equation
Will be y - - let us use this point -
y = 25 = mile I / 13
× x - this point, ie 5
We know that point 5.25 is on the line
If y-25 = inclination, we created it
X x - 5
And Antina
This is
If you want, you can use algebra to
Put it in the cross-slope model, Lee
In MX + B, you see them
Are quite equal
Let's solve one another
He gave us the inclination
Which is 3/5, the y-junction is -3
If here, directly, this seems easy to put
In the cross-slope model
Model of intersection of inclination
The equation of this line is y = inclination 3 / 5x
+ Intersection y, i-3
We will be finished
But how do you put it in the tilt point model?
Point of inclination
Well, we know the inclination
We know that m = 3/5
But do you know any point on this line?
We need a point and inclination to put it in
Model tilt point
Well, we know one point
Know the intersection of y
The y-junction is -3
This means that when x = 0, the y = -3
If the point is, 0, -3
You can try to find other points
You can say, oh, when x = 5
The y = 0
These are all the things that you can try
But these are located here
The intersection of y is -3
That means that point 0, -3 is located on the line
Let's write it down on the point-of-tilt model
y - y value of this, if y - - 3 =
Tilt 3/5 × x - this x value, this
Axis x, x - 0
This is a point-tilt model
It can be y + 3 = 3/5 × - we can
We write x x - 0
If you really want to make it look like a model point of inclination
This would be the model of the point of inclination, but it is somewhat naive
Write x - 0
You can write y + 3 = 3 / 5x
It's not 100% clear that it's a model image point of inclination
right Now
But I think you do not need to write x - 0
As it is clear, until you move from here to there, you should
You subtract 3 from both parties and you will get it
They are almost equal
I mean, they are equal in terms of representation
They are also equal in how they are written
You have to subtract 3 from both ends
Equation for those
Let's solve one another
Let's put this model as a point of inclination
We have given information
We gave the equation as f (x)
In this equation, when x = -7,
f (x) = 5
And tell us that when x =
3, then f (x) = -4
Thus, we can find the inclination first
Inclination, equal to the change in y / change in x
Let's do it
It is 4 - 5/3 - 7
It is equal to -4.5 =
Then 3 - 7, equal to 3
+ 7 = 10
If the tilt is 9 / 10-
And even put it in the tilt point model
This is simple
Model tilt point
Will be y - let us do it that way - y
- - Ask her - 3 = - I will do this
In green - = tilt, ie =
9/10, × x this - this is the coordinate
x - 4
Then we can shut it down
This is a point-tilt model
We can simplify this little negative
We can rewrite it to y-3 = -9/10
X x + 4
We're done
.